come in hello mr. O'Brien we are very
excited to have you here at comic-con oh
thank you young man
here is your suit for tonight suit wait
a minute that's my suit for tonight
do I look like a banker to you no yes
maybe I'm gonna wear a suit okay this is
comic-con they worship superheroes here
and I'm an honest-to-god superhero
actually middle-aged comedian I'm 38
years old
Oh sir 44 this is quite sad watch this
[Music]
nothing happened yeah because you didn't
click your heels together and say
there's no place like home there's no
place like home
oh that's Dorothy from The Wizard of do
you want a tip okay you get your tip if
you do it there's no place like home
there's no place like home there's no
place like home
[Music]
[Music]
well what do you think look great but
those muscles are clearly fake muscles
may be fake but this is
it's 2018 read the room oh so this is
not don't be or do more of the fire less
of this good point
thank you old chum to the fair
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you wait
thank you
thank you
shaving thank you very much yeah good
evening ladies and gentlemen I am Conan
O'Brien and these are the best Spanx
I've ever worn you like this right
$14 t.j.maxx that's a true story
very excited about this special suit
I'll have you know this suit is
specially designed to repel bullets and
women so and men too apparently except
for that guy this guy likes what he sees
[Applause]
players Germans crazy this is our fourth
year here at comic-con
yeah thinking about it this is number
four us if you count them like Star Wars
episodes this is our first good one
[Applause]
the perfect audience for that joke yeah
everything yeah yeah okay
can they went back and the mean we hope
quick announcement this week following
comic-con is BroNYCon for fans
oh my god
BroNYCon for fans of My Little Pony yeah
admission admission is $5 for kids and
$10 for people who probably shouldn't be
around kids I hope you're all having a
really good time because let's face it
it is a non-stop party here in San Diego
this weekend just guys guys if you can't
get laid at comic-con then you're at the
right place
mr. robot on second thought maybe you
should wear this suit you look like a
jackass I disagree I think the audience
likes this
I think they'd like to have a closer
look at this suit
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we have already glasses ladies gentlemen
we have a great show
the cast of glass starring Bruce Willis
samuel l.jackson Sarah paulsen
however civility to them
[Applause]
[Music]
you